- [Narrator] We're told
that millions of Americans
rely on caffeine to get
them up in the morning.
Which is true, although, if I
drank caffeine in the morning,
I've very sensitive.
I wouldn't be able to sleep at night.
Here's nutritional data
on some popular drinks
at Ben's Beans coffee shop.
All right, so here we
have the different names
of the drinks.
And then here we have
the type of the drink,
and it looks like they're
either hot or cold.
Here we have the calories
for each of those drink.
Here we have the sugar content in grams
for each of those drinks.
And here we have the
caffeine in milligrams
for each of those drinks.
And then we are asked,
the individuals in this data set are,
and then we have three choices.
Ben's Beans customers.
Ben's Beans drinks.
Or the caffeine contents.
Now, we have to be careful.
When someone says the
individuals in a data set,
they don't necessarily mean
that they have to be people.
They could be things.
And the individuals in this data set,
each of these rows, they're referring
to a certain type of drink
at Ben's Beans coffee shops.
So the different types of
drinks that Ben's Beans offers,
those are the individuals
in this data set.
So they're Ben's Beans drinks.
Next, they ask us the data set contains,
and they say how many variables
and how many of those
variable are categorical.
So if we look up here,
let's look at the variables.
So this first column
is essentially giving
us the type of drink.
This wouldn't be a variable,
this would be more of an identifier.
But all of these other columns
are representing variables.
So, for example, type is a variable.
It can either be hot or cold.
And because it can only take
on one of kind of a number
of bucket, it's either
going to be hot or cold.
It's going to fit in
one category or another.
And you don't just have two categories,
you could have more than two categories.
But it isn't just some
type of variable number
that could take on a
bunch of different values.
So this right over here
is a categorical variable.
Calories is not a categorical variable.
You could have something
with 4.1 calories.
You could have something with 178.
Things aren't fitting into nice buckets.
Same thing for sugars
and for the caffeine.
These are quantitative variables
that don't just fit into a category.
And so here I would say
that we have four variables,
one, two, three, four.
One of which is categorical.
So that would be choice A over here.